i had a damn dough my god i had a donut
you know i had a oh man i had it done
you ever had a doughnut where you just
where you eat i mean the whole time i'm
eating it all i could hear my
head i could hear that song uh i bet
they can't i bet you can't do it like me
but you can't do it like me
oh i bet you can't do it like me
i think it's like a rap song of you know
it's a urban real that buddhist checker
but you can do it like me you know i
mean this thing
man i put a
look and i cut this thing into quarters
because i knew out the gate this was a
bad
[ __ ] this little donut
this little sugar cinderella this [ __ ]
about to [ __ ]
turn into a damn taste gasm at
midnight at the stroke of 12 in my mouth
this thing i could
i cut it into quarters
and that's how old i am if somebody asks
you how old you are you say well i'm at
the age where i
will cut a doughnut in the quarters
that's a that's an interesting age baby
that's an interesting age out there and
i cut this back i mean this [ __ ] was
from atlanta you know what i'm saying
this
was about that life but you can't do it
like me
this [ __ ] was about that life uh
you know i mean this [ __ ] had a couple
gun shots on her you know a couple gun
uh
gun shots and her thigh she was about
that life
and i cut that thing into quarters and i
had it man it's from five daughters
bakery it was in uh
out here in the central east and it was
oh
oh my god
this thing made me wanna damn
i had to check with the lord and make
sure we was good after that thing
because it was good man
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering
how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been